hey guys pete here now we're not in
kansas anymore
we go back across the border into kansas
city missouri where we see that the gang
war is on
today we're looking at fargo season 4
episode 10.
i'm gonna break it all down for you
we've just got one more episode left
after this one
and i feel like they did pick up some
momentum here things are starting to
fall into place
the story refocused itself around ethel
rita which i think is a great decision
the sort of really big cast that was all
over the place
is starting to get down to just the
important characters for the ending
i will give you a spoiler warning i'm
going to talk about everything that's
happened in fargo up to this point so if
you haven't watched episode 10 yet
you're going to want to go get caught up
first please hit the subscribe button on
your way out go watch the episode which
is titled happy
and then come back watch the recap and
review and join the conversation in the
comments
there is blood on the streets of kansas
city we get a montage
of gangsters clashing in the streets
graphic photos of dead bodies
and headlines that say gang war erupts
and violence reigns
and we can see that it is deadly over at
the smutney's funeral home we see they
have bodies all over the place
later we'll learn that loys lost 27 men
apparently at some time after the events
of the train station
otis weff has decided he wants to be a
good cop
he goes straight he brings the fada
brothers in
since he used to work for them they're
not happy about it especially josto
and he's got other stuff to worry about
as well abel tells him that new york
city wants the violence to stop
it's too noisy joe bulows on hand and
even guytano thinks that they should
settle things down that josto's making
it personal
it's bad for business josto comes up
with the idea that they can't work with
loy so they need to find someone who
they can manipulate to put in his place
everyone seems to think that's a good
way to go with it and he also goes ahead
and says that they need to take out otis
we see that lloyd's moved himself into
an upscale hotel while the war is going
on
his wife's there she's given him a
haircut and he's talking openly about
his plan this turns out to be because he
needs to ask for help from this guy
happy which is a name that we've heard a
couple times from leon
remember leon was the guy who was always
trying to work his way up the ladder
until he crossed the line talking about
dr senator
which ended in loy beating him with a
belt
happy's an interesting character he has
a guy stand behind him with photos of
his elders i guess
it's never explicitly stated but that's
what it seems like
he's a country boy according to buell
and it turns out he does have a grudge
about what happened with leon
he tells lloyd that he should have
reached out to him he talks about the
importance of promises
and things aren't looking good until
buell steps in and reminds him of how
close she was with his mother
he comes around and for some concessions
he offers up his muscle for two weeks
biel and lloyd talk after he leaves and
she thinks it's going to be enough time
however it turns out they're wrong
sensing loy's weakness
happy decides to go visit the fadas and
he looks for a better deal with them
this is exactly what josto was looking
for he can put leon in
and have him take care of loy and leon
says his only regret is that he can't
kill him twice
they work out the details they'll get
all eloy's territory plus a cut of
trucking
and that all seems to be working itself
out until josto's would-be
father-in-law shows up to call off the
wedding in the process of that he pisses
off gaetano to the point that he gets
punched in the face a couple of times
before he leaves
when we get a moment where he says you
hit him for me
i'm touched and i have to say as goofy
as it sounds
there's something that works about these
two being on the same team we see that
go even a little further later while
they're staking out
otis place gaetano tells them the story
about how he got sent back to italy
we learned that he fell in love with a
girl when he was 11.
her father tried to kill him so he
defended himself with a broken piece of
glass
stabbed him in the eye and they get this
touching moment where you get the
feeling that gaetano's gonna die pretty
soon
we had seen ethel rita researching at
the library
we saw that she was looking up
obituaries but weren't sure exactly what
she was up to
at home she talks to her mom on the
porch asking about auntie zellmere who
i think we'll probably see again in the
finale and then we find out the details
of the curse
ethel rita's great-great-grandfather was
on a slave ship traveling to america
the captain of the ship was theodore
roach which de bruyle describes as
the devil himself she tells this story
about the slaves who were kept below the
deck
nearly drowning with roach just watching
and laughing
they didn't drown and ethel rita's
great-great-grandfather got his revenge
by
choking roach to death he's followed
their family ever since
and dabrell doesn't think they can get
rid of him loy's oldest boy lamail comes
out on the porch and joins them
after de bruyne leaves etherita tells
him he wants to talk to his father
before he can respond orienta shows up
things escalate pretty quickly she wants
the ring back
and she even threatens to call the cops
at the rita knows she won't do that
because she's seen the closet she knows
about her secrets
all of that comes out and by the end
orienta has no choice but to walk away
she gets in some jabs and talks down to
etherita
trying to intimidate her she delivers
one of the best lines of the episode
where she says
what does it feel like to be so sure
you're right and know
that nobody cares i'll see you in your
dreams
it's not like lemuel can do much there
but he definitely comes off as
protective and when he's asked about
being her boyfriend he says he's more
like a
suitor so there's something going on
there i'm not exactly sure what to say
about the ghost at this point
considering we'll see him again in a
minute beyond the origin story
the thing that stands out is de bruyle
saying that he likes sunshine
that seems important although we do see
him again and when we do
i don't see anything that connects that
together what happens is that orienta
sneaks into the house when everyone's
asleep she has a syringe she's about to
do her thing she's about to kill ethel
rita
and then she recognizes the presence of
rhodes it seems like she feels them
there
and she gets scared off she screams and
then the next time we see her she looks
shook across the street at her own place
where the police are inside waiting for
her dr harvard woke up
he told him what happened and now
they're gonna take her into custody
as they're taking her out we see
everyone from the smutney's place out
front on the porch watching
we do get to check in with satchel who's
still walking down the road with rabbit
we see him grab a ball of milk off
someone's porch
and then later a couple of rednecks pull
up and start messing with him
a different side of him emerges here he
pulls out the gun
says this is my world i'm the boss i
tell you what to do
and they leave and it makes you think
that we're probably going to see him
again in the finale
probably back in kansas city it's pretty
curious this turn
especially if this is mike milligan
we're watching knowing where he's going
to end up
i said earlier otis was playing the good
cop again
we see him return home the fodders who
were having their brotherly moment
are waiting outside joe beulo had gone
in and destroyed
his hummels he also desecrated the
picture of his fiancee
otis hears a noise so he takes off
outside he actually trips on the way to
his car which is kind of funny
once he gets inside he's dealing with
his ocd symptoms all of his little ticks
and he realizes the fadas are in front
of him in their car
gaitano comes for otis and we see him
struggling and it's almost like he makes
peace with the idea that he can't
control what's about to happen
in that way it's kind of a fitting end
for him and it's kind of a relief to
have him
out of the mix gaitano looks like he's
somewhat affected by it
and josso calls to him telling him to
hurry up as he's going back to the car
he trips and ends up shooting himself on
the way down
and definitely kills himself justo goes
back to check and it's clear that he
blew off the top of his skull
he flees the scene and we see otis there
in his car with a smile on his face
i actually like this end for gaetano i
didn't necessarily see it coming how it
happened but like i said earlier when
they were having that conversation and
they had the hug at the end it really
felt like gaetano wasn't gonna make it
through the episode so
that added to the tension as he was
coming up to otis's car
and after he shoots him you're like okay
well that's done now what's going to
happen
and boom gaitano goes down as well so we
have some stories coming to an end
we see things moving along and the
episode wraps up with a meeting that
sets up the finale
ethel rita goes to lloyd's hotel to talk
to him
she comes prepared she impresses him
because she knows about the painting he
has there
she lays out that she wants her family's
business back in her estimation they've
done enough work to pay it off
he's not interested in giving it back he
tells her that's not how it works
and then she pulls out donatello
fodder's ring and puts it on the table
she explains that she hasn't told him
the priceless part of this yet and when
he hears that he's gonna give them back
their business
she tells him about orienta and how she
poisons her patients and then keeps
these
items after as trophies that's what the
ring
is and she wanted to find out who it was
from so we figure out that her time at
the library that's what she was looking
up
before telling him that final bit of
information she makes some promise that
her parents will get the business back
and their debts will be clear
because what she's gonna tell him is
gonna help him win his war
he swears that if she can do that she
can have whatever she wants
she shows him the obituary where we see
donatella fada wearing the ring
and when he looks at it he smiles at her
and she smiles back
and that's where things end it's not
exactly clear how he's going to use this
information but we can tell that he
thinks it's valuable
so as i mentioned in the beginning i did
think they picked up some momentum here
it's good to see stories coming to
conclusions it's good to see things
starting to fall into place
i've still had a lot of problems with
this season like i've talked about in my
previous videos
i don't think this makes up for a lot of
those things i think those problems are
still there
and while it may not elevate it to being
a great season of tv i feel like
at least right now it looks like it
might have a good ending
overall i think it just works a lot
better when we focus on ethel rita we've
had a sense that she was going to be
important to the end game she was so
important in the beginning and then she
just sort of drifted into the background
for too long
i haven't had too much time to come up
with a theory about what
exactly that ring means for him winning
the war
it was kind of funny when he looked at
the paper he looked at her like oh i see
what you're saying
and it didn't click with me right at
that moment but ethel rita did see josto
at orienta's house
so she knows they're connected i'm
guessing now he could pin the death of
his father
on josto that could be bad news if new
york found that out you know that he did
that to take
power they wouldn't be okay with that he
doesn't know gaetano's dead yet so
he might also be thinking in that sense
but either way i think he knows he could
take that information to abel
and count on him to be sensible about it
maybe i'll think about it and do another
video this week about end game theories
or something like that
i'm excited to see where they go with it
i do expect satchel to return
i'm hoping we'll see more as elmer and i
would be shocked if we didn't see more
orienta
the fact that she had the ring seems
like she has to be involved with
whatever happens in the finale
and i don't think the idea about the
ghost interrupting that didn't really
feel like an
ending to the etherida orienta story it
was good it wasn't perfect i mean it was
kind of a weird jump i did enjoy
episode 9 and i thought that that was
good to have that self-contained story
and i think that's good for the ending
but if you think about where episode 8
left off like it's not exactly a
smooth transition there was this big
shootout at the train station and no one
even really mentions that here
and now that otis is dead i don't really
think they're going to bring that back
up
except for like i said i do think zelmer
will return
and maybe that's just enough gaitano and
josto were naturally
upset about their mother and then it
flipped to him telling him hey you're
taking it too personal you know
and orienta was getting ready to flee
town but i guess when she figured out it
was at the rita that was enough that she
wanted to take her out before she went
anywhere
so yeah i'm excited to see how they wrap
it up and i'm excited to hear what you
think so let me know in the comments
what do you think lloyd's plan is do you
think he's gonna survive like i really
don't think he's gonna live to the end
of the season
and let me know what else you're
thinking about going into the finale
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already
thanks for watching guys i'll talk to
you soon